il ya eu beaucoup étaient avec nous
aussi tu as 19 ans théo toi tu as été
harcelés de décison jusqu'à ses 18 ans à
l'école aujourd'hui tu as fondé une
association pour venir en aide aux
jeunes victimes de harcèlement on en
parlera juste après est ce que tu te
souviens de la première fois où tu as
été victime de harcèlement
aujourd'hui j'ai des lunettes mais avant
je n'avais pas et je touchais d'un oeil
ouais mais c'est parti de ça c'était le
bigleux et ça commence par ce qu'il faut
et que le harcèlement scolaire c'est
qu'en fait ça commence par quelque chose
de très simple en fait
le jeûne ne sont pas content en fait
cela il sort une seringue vannes ça ça
commence alors une vanne et puis laval
avait ressortir et pulvar revenir puis
on a un autre qui va le dire tous et sa
fille ça va ça va se propager dans toute
l'école et c'est ça qui va en fait faire
que derrière le jeune victime a presque
du coup comment dire se remettre en
question lui même et de se dire
peut-être que c'est de ma faute
au final est ce que c'est de ma faute
que je suis différent donc j'ai le
mérite d'être harcelés et est donc ça a
commencé comme ça alors donc au départ
c'était voilà c'était à cause de toute
petite différence physique voilà qu'on
voit même plus d'ailleurs maintenant
voilà je lis est ce que vous vous
reconnaissez les choses qui vous ont pas
voir arriver à l'école exactement la
même chose
c'est vrai que quand on voit dans le
film quand on lui donne des coups dans
le dos les coups dans le dos chamakh
vous passer quelque part on nous donne
une bourrade dans le dos voire des
croche patte voir des et que l'instit se
retient de rire
dax a cédé truc je vous garantis ça
marque à vie un bien sûr alors ensuite
qu'est ce que tu subissait au quotidien
ce que il s'était juste devant la ddt et
des insultes de des blagues et des
mauvaises blagues ou bien s'il y avait
des violences physiques également en
fait bas sur toute la partie primaires
ça a commencé vers c'était vraiment
porté sur des insultes sur la différence
physique donc la vue après ça a été le
poids et puis c'était aussi la
différence par rapport aux niveaux
scolaire pareil comme théo du coup tu
travaillais très bien oui je rentre en
grande section je savais déjà lire donc
c'était voilà déjà qui avait voilà y
avait beaucoup de monde et d'avoir des
mauvaises notes ont fait basse et ça
c'est à dire que par exemple bas du cou
fallait pas que j'intervienne en classe
fallait que je reste quand j'avais la
réponse match je n'avais pas ma main
parce que du coup fallait laisser parler
les autres fallait que je me que je me
rabaisse j'avais tendance à se mettre
devant la classe de tous devant on me
demandait de mettre au fond et donc ça
c'est vraiment un parti primaires et
puis après très vite au collège là ça
commence avec les coûts
donc par exemple il y avait un rituel
c'est à dire qu'avant chaque pause midi
après chaque pause midi j'avais le
rituel de devoir attendre devant le mur
compte frappe en fait non y avait
c'était le rituel de dire que j'avais
deux groupes classe c'est un petit à
petit établissement
donc c'était avec deux classes par
niveau j'avais deux classes et à chaque
fois il y avait un ou deux jeunes qui
ressortait qui qui me frappait et toi tu
te mettais dans le mur après c'était
devenu un rituel un rituel
pire que ça c'est qu'en vacances
scolaires ou quand il est pas court
presque je souffrais de ne pas être
harcelé non alors il s'étonnait
indépendance et c'est devenu en fait
c'était devenu tout rituel c'était
devenu ton quotidien élite utiliser
quelque chose non je dis que c'est le
syndrome de stockholm et entretien quel
courage de venir de venir témoigner
comme ça à la télé parce que c'est une
façon de prendre des risques aussi parce
que demain quand tu vas aller à l'école
bien sûr va t'en parler et c'est donc
bravo tu as vraiment beaucoup de plages
alors hugo comment tu as pu mettre fin à
ces harcèlements ce que tu allais voir
les professeurs ou ce que tu l'as dit
tout de suite à tes parents
alors en fait moi j'ai commencé par en
décembre par les eaux corps parce que tu
as eu douze ans de harcèlement de ce que
tu dis de 6 ans à 18 ans c'est
incroyable
en fait c'est au final ça s'est terminé
parce que j'avais terminé ma scolarité
ah ouais c'est à dire que j'ai eu mon
bac et voilà c'était fini c'est fou mais
ya pas eu de fin en soi prématurée est
pire que ça c'est qu'en plus ce mois du
coup quand je à mon époque où j'étais
scolarisé du coup les réseaux sociaux
commencent à prendre de l'ampleur est en
fait en quatrième j'ai été victime de
cyber harcèlement sans que moi même je
sois sur les réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs qui avait eu un voyage
scolaire et on m'avait filmé à mon insu
dans le bus en train de dormir
oui je ronfler et ben ronfle aussi bon
bah bienvenue au club
voilà et est en fête et bah du coup sans
que je m'en sens que le sache
la vidéo avait passé sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans le village dans lequel
j'étais il y avait deux établissements
de collège et ça a fait le tour en fait
et ce qui m'a choqué ce qui a fait
prendre conscience de l'ampleur des
réseaux sociaux
je marchais dans mon village avec ma
mère c'est un petit village donc rouge
où j'étais scolarisé donc et je vois des
jeunes que je connais pas ou
potentiellement de l'autre collège qui
commence à rire et qui sortent leurs
téléphones avec talent est reconnu et en
fait
alors que moi je les connaissais pas si
vous monde me connaissait parce que du
coup gérer cette vidéo qui tournait sur
moi incroyable c'est incroyable c'est ça
fait froid dans le dos non mais vraiment
c'est donc été la seule tête elle seule
de ta classe aa être victime
d'harcèlement mata sont souvent sans fin
souvent ça une victime en fait non love
mais franchement je te lis hugo moi moi
ton témoignage vraiment une bouleverse
mais pourquoi les professeurs n'ont rien
fait c'est ça ce que je te demande pas
ce que tu ne vas aller les voir ces
incroyables notamment mathieu nais mais
voilà parce que moi ce que j'en veux
surtout aux professeurs sont très émus
mature et parce que j'avais un
professeur est pas évidemment ils sont
très touchées on vient des professeurs
et les professeurs ils ont un travail
oui dans leur cas et dans le bien
évidemment à qui vous pouvez parler si
vous parlez à vos parents vous avez peur
que leers et leur donne encore plus
méchant si vous parlez aux professeurs
vous devenu le fayot près tout le monde
parce que donc ça veut dire que vous ne
pouvez vous n'avez aucune solution est
donc forcément vous vous isolez et c'est
là que le danger devient vraiment grave
parce que vous devenez totalement seul
et quand on s'isole a forcément commence
à voir des mauvaises pensées ont fait
des bêtises et ses jambes et aux
professeurs pour moi dans mon cas en
tout cas c'est pas compliqué dans une
pension dans des dortoirs de voir qu'un
hacker plus mal traités que les autres
devancent il faut juste regarder un
petit peu et pas se dire que ça s'arrête
à 18h et courante je parle pas pour tous
les professeurs mais ouvrez un peu plus
tes yeux ça se voit là dans le film
qu'on a vu qu'on avait eu effectivement
et ce garçon qui sait frapper dans le
dos elle cherche même pas savoir ce qui
s'est passé mais mam tu sors il faut
juste ouvrir un petit peu plus les yeux
et regarder et quand on regarde on voit
souvent ce qu'on a devant les a
justement j'aimerais qu'on voit juste il
y avait eu après le téléfilm de tf1 y
avait un documentaire sur le le vrai
show là ton destin
1 voilà que tu as tu as regardé le
calvaire de jonathan oui et j'ai comment
dire je suis reconnu au final dans le
dans la vie de jonathan sur certains
points on a quand chaque enfant est
unique donc chacun à sa manière au final
aussi d'exprimer aussi cette souffrance
moi personnellement ça a été la
nourriture et donc c'est en plus ça a
été un moyen de se moquer de moi encore
plus du coup parce que moi j'étais le
gros de service pour d'autres ce sera
d'autres moyens mais c'est vrai que du
coup dans l'histoire de nathan il ya
vraiment on s'y reconnaît tous en fait
quand on sait qu'ils racontent qu aucune
personne de l'établissement scolaire ne
lui est venu en aide
regardez bien attendre
et mon estimation une passe en europe on
risque de tuer tes parents que je savais
un peu ce que je voulais faire jouer
mieux supprimer ou terrorisés jonathan
s'arrête au supermarché pour acheter une
bouteille d'alcool à brûler et se dirige
vers le canal qui passe près de chez lui
elle chez les élèves my bousculé dans la
création à lui frappé mais en gros tu as
passé et donc j'en ai par le professeur
et le professeur et nanti d'un vu la
scène et il a dit il faut que je joue
avec toi je me suis dit si le prof crois
ça c'est que après avoir par les grands
je n'arrive plus à suivre des cours
j'arrivais pas à réfléchir je n'arrivais
pas à me concentrer
dans le vestiaire il n'y a pas de
surveillants il ya pas d'adultes
vraiment que tu as trouvé y procédera
aussi au jeu peut-être plus tard c'est
aussi alors moi j'ai une question à se
poser
hugo avant gilles voulait dire quelque
chose oui j'ai été très émue j'ai
rencontré jonathan
oui et il ya quelque chose qui m'a
bouleversé dans son histoire alors il
était à bout ils n'avaient plus d'issue
donc il a voulu s'immoler se suicider et
encore aujourd'hui il a peur de parler
de ses harceleurs c'est ça qui est fou
et je lui ai dit mais pourquoi tu n'en
parles pas pourquoi tu ne les dénoncent
pas parce que je peux les recroiser
parce qu'on ne sait jamais parce qu'il
peut y avoir une menace alors les
paroles se libèrent mais c'est encore là
dessus qu'il faut travailler c'est que
cette peur des harceleurs elles soient
complètement élimination qui loin de
casser trop les profanes de l'éducation
nationale est exemplaire il faut un
super travail difficiles les les vrais
coupables sont seiler cela a bien sûr et
ben c'est sûr ça va
hugo toi est-ce que ce que tu as peur de
retrouver ceux qui nous harcelaient ou
pas du tout ça était sorti de tout ça
aujourd'hui plus en fait où les routes
aujourd'hui presque d'ordinaire si c'est
vrai pourquoi parce que j'en suis sorti
plus fort en fait au final vraiment au
jour et acta continue à bien travailler
à l'école
non ça c'est clair que j'avais tout le
monde le disait j'avais des potentiels
enfin des capacités a surtout
mathématiques par exemple assez
importante
oui je me suis retrouvé à quatre au bac
s en avant ah ouais tu avais pas du tout
bosser mon bac non annoncée même pas ce
même pire que ça c'est qu'en fait
en fait on est tellement focus sur se
défendre se protéger qu'au final on
oublie tout et mon bac je les ai eus à
10 02 ah ouais vraiment est passé comme
ça voilà bon alors que tout le monde
mais enfin attendez de moi et comment
dire savais que j'avais le potentiel
pour avoir bien plus et qu'est ce que tu
veux aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je suis en études de
marketing se passe bien ça se passe
super bien et est heureux aujourd'hui je
suis heureux et surtout je transforme
cette souffrance en force en fait et
c'est vraiment et ça me reconstruis
qu'est-ce qui tourne vite et ses parents
ty télé voir ou pas d'accord je l'aurais
pas en fait c'est ce qui est assez fou
c'est que moi donc j'ai commencé à
parler par aux profs aux surveillants là
j'ai une déception folle en fait de
l'argent de leur part et après j'avais
parlé par an et c'est vrai que très vite
mais en fait ils sont retrouvés face à
un mur ou aussi parce que quand ils sont
allés voir rencontrer la proviseure
rencontrer les surveillants il ya un
blocage qui se fait en fait il ya alors
certes il faut pas leur jeter la pierre
aux surveillants aux enseignants aux
directeurs mais je pense qu'il ya un
gros problème à résoudre
c'est la prise en charge la parole de
sûr que ce soit la fois de la victime du
tempo des témoins mais aussi des parents
est ce que tu penses que ça va mieux
maintenant
maintenant quand on en parle à la télé
qu'on a des reportages en fait tu crois
qu'il ya un mieux en fait que tu crois
que ça va aller mieux
le mieux c'est qu'aujourd'hui et pas une
seule personne en france ne connaît pas
qui ne sait pas ce que c'est que l'heure
seulement stern avait sa jeu c'est
indéniable on peut pas être contraire
c'est une vraie réussite